i'm very happy and honored to have been
asked to give this
keynote address to stoicon x new england
2020 we're in the year of virtual
conferences
and so i've pre-recorded this in order
to make sure there won't be any
bandwidth issues
but also so i can share this with a
larger worldwide audience after this
conference
has concluded because the the things
that i'm going to talk about are
in many respects quite timely and
also perennial i want to talk about
stoicism
in the workplace now the stoics
of course didn't talk an awful lot about
workplaces in
general and they certainly didn't talk
about the modern workplace but
many of the things that that we can
learn from them and apply
will help us out within the workplaces
that we
are currently you know doing our work in
and in many cases for some of us living
in as well those of us
who are working from home and many of us
work in in virtual context
as well where we're kind of you know
interconnected with others
through this wonderful medium of the
internet now
i do want to talk about a particular
case that i think some of you may have
already heard of if you haven't we're
gonna we're gonna run through it
and it it has to do with somebody
who got fired and then
used stoicism in order to justify
his behavior in a way that really is
quite
non-stoic or perhaps even anti-stoic
and it made its way into the court
system in britain
and stoicism is being now recognized as
a protected category so we're going to
talk about
what that means and whether or not this
person was
actually doing the right thing or
arguably stoic in in
his behavior answer of course is he was
not at all
and we're going to be using this as a
way to explore well how would you behave
as a stoic in the workplace as it turns
out there's a lot of useful
information in classic stoic texts and
then we can also
think out these matters as we have to do
as modern stoics
in the present adapting all of these
things
so i'm going to talk a bit about the
case and then
i'm also going to talk about some some
real basics that we want to keep in mind
when we're thinking about
stoicism or really any intentional way
of living
within the workplace and then there's a
number of what we can call stoic
points that i'm going to lead us through
so i
the first of these is whether as stoics
we should expect other people
in the workplace to buy into stoicism or
not
and what the implications for that are
the second has to do
with truth the stoics believe that human
beings have an innate
desire for truth and value truth
and there was an appeal to truth as
something like a transcendent value in
this
workplace case so we're going to look at
what stoics actually have to say
about truth then we're also going to
talk about something else that the
stoics thought was
absolutely central to human beings our
social
nature we are social beings there are a
number of implications
coming out of that for how we ought to
live work think in the workplace
we're also going to talk about the
workplace as you might say
a field of things that the stoics called
externals or
indifference and whether that means that
we should not care about them
or whether that means that we need to be
careful
in how we're dealing with these matters
and then
this the second to last thing i want to
talk about is something that i think we
all need to keep in mind
every once in a while some of us need to
be reminded of it a little bit more
which is that we're not the sage we
are uh the the procoptone or the
proficience if we're using greek or
latin or you could say the stoic in
training and by aspiration that means
that we're constantly
trying to work on ourselves and that
means we're going to screw up and so we
should think about well what should we
do
when we screw up what should we do when
we make mistakes
finally i do want to address the issue
that that we absolutely have to bring up
what if you're in a workplace that's
actually bad
in some respects should you as a stoic
say well
i'll just put up with it this is really
a great opportunity for me to
train my stoicism or should you say well
this is actually exploitative or this is
abusive and at a certain point
i should not have to put up with this so
we're going to talk about each of these
points
i'm not going to try to cover everything
in the depth or detail that it deserves
obviously each of these is something we
could do a much longer talk about
but hopefully in the q a and discussion
we can explore this a bit more
the case that i have in mind to use here
as you might say examples of how not to
behave
as a stoic pertains to a
firing of an employee whose name was
samuel jackson
he worked for the little corporation as
apparently a communications
specialist and he got fired because
he engaged in some stereotyping and it's
not clear exactly when he did this it
may he may have said this out loud he
may have put this into an email
and um he said some some bad things
about
asians as a entire class
i mean it's very there's a little bit of
a side note if you think about
asians it's not a nationality it
encompasses everybody from the indian
subcontinent
way up into you know north east asia
and so this is you know quite a
statement for him to make
i'm not going to repeat the statement
because i don't want to engage in
stereotyping like that he was called
out for that and he was told he needed
to apologize
and he gave what the the corporation
thought was an insufficient apology and
he was
fired now notice he's a communications
person
so we have a role here in which you'd
expect that this person would be
cognizant of you know the niceties of
social conventions and how to
communicate effectively
and what not to say as well so
now it goes before courts and
uh here's here's where it gets
particularly interesting
he claimed stoicism as a pretext for
what he had done in the workplace and
why it was okay for him to do it
in the article in in hr review it says
stoic beliefs meant that he was bound to
say what he liked
without fear of offending other people
and and
he clarifies that what he wanted to say
was what he thought to be the truth
and without any repercussions so he's
making the case that what stoicism
really amounts to
is such a great love for truth that you
should say
whatever is on your mind if you think
that it's true without caring about
how it's going to affect anyone else
consequences in terms of
how they might you know view you
consequences in terms of how those words
might affect them and so
under the equality act of 2000 in
britain
stoicism is now being considered
a protected belief now
that's kind of interesting because it
means that there will be other people
making similar
arguments and using stoicism as a
pretext for similar behavior in the
workplace
in the court case he actually said that
the realization that the consequences of
what i say would cause offense
would not stop me from saying it so here
we're posed with a really
interesting case did he get stoicism
right
is he in a certain respect abusing
stoicism
by claiming its mantle in order to avoid
having to take any responsibility for
his actions
these are questions that we can think
out a further one that we can think out
if we've decided that he actually got
things wrong is
well what can we learn from this example
of
how not to behave in the workplace let's
start with talking about some real
basics and this goes beyond stoicism as
such and would extend to any sort of
virtue ethics tradition or wisdom
tradition or any
intentional way of living i think
there's there's
four main things that we want to keep in
mind when we're talking
about the workplace and how we're
applying
a philosophy or way of life to it
so the first is how we should behave
towards others how should we treat other
people
in the workplace so others is a key
dimension
and then we can also talk about
ourselves how do we evaluate
ourselves and how do we develop
ourselves
further into being you know better and
better people because that's that's what
anything that counts as a virtue ethics
ought to be
guiding us towards becoming better
people not just being complacent with
who we
currently are and then there's two other
vectors that we can talk about we can
talk about the work
itself and our roles and our duties that
come into play with that
and then we can talk about the
overarching situation
of the workplace itself which can be
understood
as a domain of all sorts of personal
interactions we can also look at it as
something like a community it could be a
very dysfunctional community
it could be a very well coordinated one
and so these four dimensions i think are
good to keep in mind
when you look at places where people are
discussing stoicism
one of the beginner mistakes that people
bring up quite often without meaning to
necessarily
is making the assumption that because
they've decided that they want to be a
stoic
and they want to start practicing
stoicism everybody else should be held
to
that as well everybody else should be
viewed as if they're stoic
so they'll say you know things like well
you shouldn't be affected by the things
that i'm saying because it's only
your judgment that makes it hurtful to
you
that is a very unstoic way to behave for
several reasons first of all it's
completely imprudent
prudence is one of the key virtues of
stoicism
and to think that somehow because one
has changed oneself a little bit
that everyone else in the world is going
to change that's complete foolishness
the opposite of prudence it's also
unjust it's placing a burden on them
that they don't actually deserve to have
and you know it there's there's other
things that we can say about it as well
but one of the problems with this case
is
i think and i'm sort of reading this
into this case
it sounds like samuel jackson is
assuming that his co-workers
really shouldn't be offended by his
using ethnic stereotypes to
characterize those who belong to that
that whole set of ethnicities really
or anybody else who might say well
that's the wrong thing to be doing in
the workplace
i find that offensive because it's
actually an unjust
action that you're engaging in and so
it's it's
you know this is i think something
really worth keeping in mind
if you're going to try to be a stoic in
the workplace
do not expect other people to suddenly
change their mentalities
and become stoic along with you
epictetus actually tells us tells us in
the end caridian
if you're going to start being a stoic
start being a philosopher keep it to
yourself for the time being
until you've managed to work on yourself
for a while
samuel jackson explained his actions by
saying that according to him stoicism
meant
that he had a duty or a right
to speak the truth as he saw it
regardless of whether it would offend
anybody or any other consequences
and he's partly right in that stoicism
does
value truth truth is is held to be
something that is a good for human being
something that we have an
innate desire for this is part of what
allows stoics to say that there's
something like a
natural law that would say that we
should actually cultivate wisdom
it doesn't say that we have an automatic
right or duty to speak our mind anytime
and as a matter of fact one of the
things if you actually are a stoic
that you should hold about truth is is
that you're probably
wrong when it comes to a lot of the
things that you think
are true ethnic stereotypes are a great
example of this
claiming that that one knows something
about an entire
swath of people and can say things about
them
i mean that should set off alarm bells
for anybody who claims to be a stoic
that's sort of like ding ding ding
wow i i have some really screwed up
preconceptions
right i have some really screwed up
judgments i have some really
screwed up opinions and i'd better start
working on these
and so this provides us with a good
place to talk about what would an
actual stoic say about this well
you know the stoics actually talked
about disciplines
and epitidis as everyone knows talks
about the discipline of desire the
discipline of action or choice and the
discipline of ascent
that entire discipline of ascent is
about how to get our ideas
right and straight in our heads seneca
talks about disciplines
in a slightly different way in letter 89
he says that that ethics is divided into
three branches
the first assigns to each thing it's
proper value and determines what it's
worth
the second deals with impulse the third
deals with actions right
the objective of ethics are to enable
you to judge what each thing is worth to
enable you to
entertain a well adjusted and controlled
impulse and the third to enable you to
achieve harmony between your impulse and
action so you can be consistent
these would seem to say that this guy
actually is not a stoic he's
he's using stoicism he's actually
untruthful
about what stoicism consists in
another key aspect of this and there's
much more that could be said about this
is that as epictetus tells us
sticking with ideas stubbornly doubling
down on them
does not actually make you a stoic or
even rational
he gives us an example somebody who made
a really stupid decision
and then pig-headedly stuck with it
against
any sort of you know argument or counter
evidence and epictetus says
the resolve to stick with something
against you know
say any outside interference that's
only good if your ideas are actually
true
clearly in this case sticking with an
ethnic stereotype and then doubling down
by refusing to apologize
properly about it and then going to
court and claiming that this
is done because of stoicism that i think
would fit
under what epictetus is talking about
another key dimension of stoic ethics is
that we
as human beings are social beings we
are not meant to be totally isolated
from each other or to push
others away as a matter of fact we're
only really following the stoic path
when we can get along with other people
there are going to be obstacles
especially when other people have
wrong-headed ideas but we should make
our
best efforts to get along so there's
this pro-social
nature and this is something that the
stoics think that we ought to work on
and expand and there's a lot of
different ways in which this can
happen we can talk about some of that in
the q
a one key element of this is that
justice is a virtue for
stoics and justice doesn't just mean
giving everybody what they deserve or
honoring commitments that we make
it also involves as you know cicero
seneca
marcus aurelius epictetus make crystal
clear
beneficence or kindness
being good to other people not doing
things that are going to be hurtful to
them in fact
doing the opposite so saying offensive
things to other people
is really going against this this
key teaching of stoicism and it's going
against the
virtue of justice another key aspect of
this
particularly important in the workplace
is understanding our roles stoic ethics
tells us
that a good portion of our duties come
from our roles and these might even be
included in our job description
for a person in communications you would
think that
communicating effectively with other
people and then being able to handle
being told that you've got something
wrong and coursing course adjusting
would be part of that and this can apply
to all of us we all have different roles
as epictetus reminds us the role of
socrates is not the role
of diogenes is not the role of xeno
socrates is supposed to go around and
ask people questions diogenes is
supposed to go around as a cynic and be
kind of a jerk but also teach people
things
xeno was a teacher right so each of us
has our workplace roles and we're
supposed to be living
up to them as best as we can another key
thing that i think can come out of stoic
philosophy and this is
really there in marcus aurelius who
reminds himself about this over and over
again but also in epictetus
is we can conceive of ourselves while
still remaining individuals as
parts of larger holes
in which we have our part to play and we
only
work well within that context by
harmonizing with
as best we can what other people are
doing and then i think we can also think
about
having proper emotional comportments
towards our fellow workers we shouldn't
be contemptuous of them
we shouldn't try to you know say things
that are going to be offensive to them
here i want to read a little passage
from marcus he says fit yourself into
accord with the things in which your
portion has been cast
and then he says and love the people
among whom your lot has fallen
but love them truly be affectionate
be kind be good to other people within
the workplace
that is how a stoic would approach
dealing with matters in their their
relations with other co-workers with
customers with
uh so you know supervisors subordinates
all the people who we have to engage
with we should have the proper
components towards them one of the
challenges for applying stoicism within
the workplace
is looking at all the things that the
workplace comprises
and not jumping to the conclusion
that none of it really matters from a
stoic perspective as a matter of fact
it does matter even though most of what
we're dealing with
do fall into what stoics call the
externals
or the indifference the indifference are
things that
don't make us either truly happy or
truly miserable because they don't by
themselves affect
our moral goodness or moral badness but
they can certainly play
a major role in it because what we do
with the indifference how we deal with
them
and how we make decisions in
prioritizing about them and
also the work that we're engaged with
that
does have an impact on us so we
can exercise the virtues of for example
courage or fortitude or temperance or
self-control
in the way that we're dealing with
things in the workplace do we stick with
our work
and diligently get through it or do we
slough off and
you know say things like well nobody's
going to notice if i cut corners over
here
that by itself may bear on something
that is indifferent
but it has to do with our character
and likewise the things that we say in
in some respects may be by themselves
indifferent but they
they have an effect on us so it's very
important to keep in mind that just
because
we say as stoics that things like
your your the amount of money that
you're getting paid
or the number of hours that you're
putting in or the boxes that you fill or
whatever it happens to be that those
things are strictly speaking
indifference they can be preferred
or rejected and the use that we make of
them
is absolutely essential in whether we're
going to become
more virtuous or more vicious
one of the things that we need to bear
in mind as i mentioned a little bit
earlier
is that if we're going to be stoics we
cannot conceive of stoicism as something
like an on off switch you picked up the
book
and now you're a stoic or you began
practicing and now you're a stoic
stoicism you might say is a continuum
and it's not even one where you
necessarily are going to make steady
progress you're going to screw up you're
going to fail
you're going to fall you're going to
make mistakes you're going to think that
you've got things right and then
eventually
re-read something and get reminded that
you've actually got some things
off you're mistaken about some things
and then what do we do in a
in a case like that do we double down
stubbornly
on saying that we're the ones who've got
it right we stick with
our truth or our claim that we're you
know loving truth and we have to say
what we're going to say
no matter what not really the stoic
thing to do
as a matter of fact we have some very
clear advice
about these sorts of things marcus
aurelius tells us
you know when people screw up we we
should tell them here's where you're
screwing up and then leave it to them to
decide
and when it's us when we screw up we
should be
amenable to other people saying man
you've really gone off
the course if i've gone off the course i
want to be
corrected epictetus will talk about the
incredible force
that habit plays and why it's so
important for us to devote
attention to what's going on in the
situations
that we're in that each time we have an
opportunity
for working on those habits making them
better
or if we're not paying attention and we
choose the wrong things
for making them worse and there's almost
nothing
worse than a wrong-headed idea about
the truth and about how one ought to
behave
you know the stoics have a sense of
compassion you might say
for people who are so off
that they think that acting like a jerk
is the right way to be so
we can take that and think about
ourselves how should we behave towards
our co-workers how should we
behave in relation to the work that
we're doing
are we measuring up to it and we don't
have to make ourselves overly anxious
about that
or obsess about it but it's something
that we should probably do
as a continual check-in and we probably
want to do that with co-workers or
colleagues whose judgment
we trust whether they're stoics or not
one of the issues that we really do have
to address and i think because there's a
lot of misunderstandings about this
deriving from
in a simplistic way using some of the
things stoics actually do
say has to do with what we
should put up with in workplaces when
we're talking about things like
abusiveness manipulativeness injustice
exploit exploitation
there's a lot of things where we might
say oh well
epictetus and marcus aurelius told us we
can put up with anything if we just put
our mind to it
and we're not really hurt by anybody
only by what we think
is going on there's a lot to that
and there are probably cases where we
should say well i need to
to toughen up a bit but there's a lot of
cases where we shouldn't actually
make that our go-to there's plenty of
cases
where people are genuinely unjust where
there's workplace bullying
where there's clear inequities where
people are being treated in ways that
they shouldn't
and the stoic thing to do in those cases
particularly if it involves others to
whom we have some sort of responsibility
is to take a stand to say this is wrong
this is unjust that is
indeed part of the virtue of justice to
take
the right stands it also requires
fortitude or courage to do so
it also requires prudence or wisdom and
so by doing that we're behaving
virtuously in our own case
there are lines that we shouldn't allow
people
to cross not because as stoics we can't
possibly handle it in some cases maybe
we can maybe we can't
as i pointed out we're all in
development so there's going to be
places where people can
get their hooks into us right and and
provoke us in certain ways
if we know that's the case we should lay
down lines where we say this is not okay
this is okay and then hopefully coach
people how to get from
this is not okay to this is okay or uh
do what we need to do in order to move
them out of that workplace
if we're the ones engaging in that we
need to fix ourselves we need to work on
ourselves
and so to come back to this case samuel
jackson was wrong
to engage in any sort of ethnic
stereotyping particularly when he had a
role to be a communications person he
was doubly wrong to use stoicism
as an excuse to double down and refuse
to give a
proper apology right he should have been
working on his character
in that case and saying oh i've screwed
up i need to fix this
the judge was wrong to accept samuel
jackson's
on its face uh claim that he was a stoic
and that this is what stoicism was the
judge probably didn't do his due
diligence in researching
whether the behavior and the
the justification actually map on to
stoicism
but we should think about what we're
willing to to go along with and what we
should allow
to happen to others particularly others
who are not claiming to
be stoics or not trying to be stoics
they are in some respects more
vulnerable
and to be a just person means to take
care
of them in the workplace as well so
stoicism is not going to say
put up with anything whatsoever whether
it's abusive or exploitative
they would say of course use the reserve
clause don't expect that when you tell
somebody that they've done something
wrong
they're automatically going to have the
result that you want or that making
rightful criticisms is automatically
going to produce
a changed workplace but we ought to
prudently justly courageously stand
up against wrong behavior and
so you know to bring this to a close i
hope that you you found this useful we
covered a couple main points of stoicism
i think that this case shows us in many
respects
interesting things about how not to be a
stoic not you know what not to claim
and hopefully it also guides us to
understanding a little bit better
how to be a stoic and what that would
look like
within the contemporary workplace
you